uh also a 19 year old freshman that
walked her home from the party
kristen never returned to her dorm room
that night and has not been seen
or heard from since that time she was
reported missing to the cal poly police
department on may
28 1996. cal poly police handled the
initial investigation into her
disappearance with the assistant
of investigators from the san luis
obispo county district attorney's office
on june 26 1996 about a month later
the san luis sheriff's office assumed
the lead investigation
in the case we have actively
investigated the case
since that time we have uh received
assistance from the fbi
california department of justice uh
numerous other law enforcement agencies
throughout the state of
california and actually out of the state
of california
i introduced detective cole for a reason
about
four years ago the board of supervisors
and
i think the chair of the board lynn
compton is here
uh granted a request that i had for a
unsolved cold case detective
many of our cold cases are actually
assigned to our detectives
in addition to their normal caseload and
kristin's was one of those cases
chris is one of the cases that i um
targeted for this position and after
granting that position
detective cole uh assumed that position
and
and has been working on kristen's case
since then
throughout our investigation paul flores
has remained a
person of significant interest there's
been some discussion of
what is a person of interest versus a
suspect and it's really a matter of
terminology
when a crime occurs everybody in
involved in that area could be a person
of interest until they're ruled
no longer of interest either through
alibi through witness through physical
evidence
but paul remained as a person of
interest and as the case progressed
became a suspect and the prime suspect
of the case
so i became sheriff in 2011
and did a complete and requested a
complete review
of all the physical evidence that had
ever been taken
in the uh in the missing person case
in late 2016
we discovered additional evidence that
confirmed that
paul was the suspect in the
disappearance
in 2019 we interviewed several witnesses
that had not been previously interviewed
uh and i'll say uh some of that
information came
came to light through the podcast that
many or you're familiar with
that was produced in eventually
uh led to our are uh interviewing that
witness
and uh with the with the knowledge of
the this game
uh discovered uh of new evidence new
witnesses sheriff's
detectives secured a court order
authorizing
the interception and monitoring of paul
flores's cell phone and text messages
this is one of many things that have
been done
over the last 10 years in february of
2020 detectives served search warrants
at the home of paul flores
as well as his sister mother and father
all simultaneously
last year physical evidence recovered
during these searches
led to the service of additional search
warrant at paul flores's residence in
april of last year
during the search warrant detectives
recovered evidence related to
the murder of kristin smart in march of
this year
detectives served another search warrant
in arroyo grande
at the home of reuben flores the father
of paul flores additional evidence
related to the smart invest
investigation was discovered that
at that time so as a result of
this evidence a san luis obispo superior
court judge signed
two arrest warrants and two additional
search warrants
at approximately zero 7 30 this morning
today both were arrested simultaneously
with a team down in san pedro california
and a team in roy grande california
and they arrested uh paul flores and his
father
reuben paul was arrested for charge of
murder
with zero bail meaning he is unable to
bail
and reuben flores was arrested as an
accessory to murder
with a bale of 250 000 we are still
currently in the process of executing
those search warrants
um could be there for the remainder of
the day or even it's tomorrow depending
on on what they find
now i understand a lot of people want to
know what we found in the detail and
that's kind of the
the question that people continuously
ask us
and ask me is what exactly did you find
and what exactly do they have that has
led to this
well i can tell you unfortunately the
search warrants were sealed which
means i cannot discuss what evidence was
found and
probably more importantly is is that we
have a due process right right now
and everybody here is is um
is is allowed that due process right
that means
it has to go to court there has to be a
trial of
of of 12 people and decide his
guilt or innocence so discussing
specific items of evidence is just not
appropriate
at this point
i will say this and this is probably a a
question that i will answer at this
point
um that we have not recovered kristin
we will continue to focus on finding her
remains
regardless of any court action so we
will
continue the process of finding out
where kristin is
we know that's important part uh or
important uh
issue with the family when i took office
one of the the first acts that i
mentioned
was re-examining starting from the
beginning and i often tell people this
that law enforcement solves crimes
really two ways
through witnesses and physical evidence
when we lack witnesses we
rely on physical evidence you hear the
news all the time about
physical evidence that has linked
somebody to a crime well that's
extremely important to solving a crime
in this case we were dealing with a case
that was
at my at my point of coming into office
about 14
years old which makes it very difficult
since that time
i believe there's a list somewhere i
can't see it
probably somewhere over here thank you
that is highlighting what i'm just about
to tell you
since i came into office in 2011 we've
served over 41 search warrants on this
case
that physical searches of 16 different
locations
one of which was back on the back hill
you may remember a few years ago
a complete re-examination of every
physical item
seized submission of 37 items
of evidence from the early days of the
case for modern dna testing
recovery of 193
items of physical evidence new physical
evidence
we've conducted approximately 137
person-to-person interviews
and in addition completed over 500
additional police reports i can tell you
this file
the size of it is probably the size if
you put it on a
room a a hard drive
it's in excess of three terabytes it's
that much
involved in this case um it's my hope
that we're able to take the first step
toward justice for the smart family
uh peace for the community some justice
out there
uh for all of us and most especially for
kristin
i have spoken to the smart family
numerous times
including including this morning
matter of fact twice today i think
they're feeling
a bit of relief but as you can imagine
until we return kristen to them
this is not over and we have committed
to them that
we are not going to stop until kristen
has been recovered no matter what the
cost
no matter what the time we're committed
to that and
i know they believe in us i know they
believe that
we will we will find kristin
so this afternoon we have turned the
case over to the san luis obispo
district attorney's office
the way the process works the warrants
that were signed by the superior court
allowed for the arrest and booking of
paul and his father reuben
now the case has been handed to the
district attorney
for review and their announcement
further proceedings i'd like to thank
my investigators there was certainly the
investigator that i introduced detective
cole
but there was detective commander that's
in the audience
a new detective commander um
many people over the years that have
worked on this case
i think the the the people that are
representing here today
myself the chief of cal poly police
uh weren't part of this investigation
weren't part of this agency
that we are all in when this happened
and i think the cooperation that's taken
place i know president armstrong has
really opened the door for us to do and
provide us anything that he
possibly can including having
this press conference here in cal poly
today
so i'd like to introduce president
armstrong
to say a few words
thank you sheriff parkinson i appreciate
so many members
of the cal poly and central coast
community san luis obispo being here
today
our cal poly and central coast
communities have watched the case of
kristen smart's
disappearance closely and hoped for
justice for kristin
and resolution for the family for years
the news today of arrest in connection
with this with the case
brings sadness but also a measure of
relief and hope for resolution
while we know that today's developments
do not represent the
end of the case it is a significant step
we at cal poly offer our thanks to
sheriff ian parkinson and his department
as well as district attorney dan dow and
his office who have worked hard to find
answers in this case for kristin
and her family i know that many across
california and the us
and many of you here today also thank
chris lambert
for his efforts as well last
our thoughts and prayers continue to be
with denise and stan smart
all of kristin's family and friends as
this process
proceeds thank you
thank you president armstrong um i am
prepared to answer any questions that
you might have just understand
as i stated that some of the items that
i
just will not be able to discuss
he was driven from san pedro and booked
into san jose county jail
uh today already so he's here parkinson
are you guys any closer to finding
christian at this point and the first
words that are being served currently
reason to believe that she may be at
rutgers home or
any of the properties belonging to the
florida family
well the first part of the the question
is are we any closer and the answer is
yes i believe we are
um but only time will tell so if
if obviously we recover we'd be making
that announcement today
in regards to the search warrants you
know we're we're after all kinds of
things physical evidence again
anything uh anything that might lead us
to the location of kristin
and as you know from the previous search
and and as you reported from this search
we're out there with you know our ground
penetrating radar
again so yes it's it's safe to say we're
we're checking everywhere possible
i i believe that that paul's arraignment
will be
on thursday um it really depends on
reuben rubin has the ability to bail out
if he bails out then he will not be
there on thursday but if he is still in
custody he will uh
too be in court on thursday
yes yes
yes sir
well as as i've i've said before um in
this case is probably the the best
illustration of it
is that it's it's not what you believe
it's what you can prove so
when when people ask why is this taking
so long
because the general public
knows this much about the case and the
cases
this big and so as it progresses
you know and when i talk about that do
do process
rights we have a right or we have a duty
an obligation to protect people that are
innocent
as well as guilty so we can't base the
rest on what we might believe it has to
be based on physical evidence
let me see if i can answer it this way
forensic physical evidence was located
and yes we believe it's it's linked to
kristin
um and yes we did find physical evidence
at uh at at least two homes
in regards to what what chris lambert
discovered
yeah you know that that that comes up
every year so since i've come into
office
we have two anniversary dates that are
are really centered around
uh kristen and that is her birthday and
that is the date she went missing
um that's typically when when interviews
you know people want to interview me or
interview the department on on kristen's
case
i've always said that those are really
good things because it's getting that
message out
i think what uh chris did with
his podcast was he took a local story
that was generally locally
and he expanded it to a national story
in international
actually i'll say because once that
message got out
um we started getting more information
now some of it is
information that we already had and new
but the value to it was is that there's
as as we see here there's a lot of
people that that are students here
that don't aren't from san luis obispo
and so
when they graduate a lot of them will
leave back to their home area or
on to pursue you know other jobs and so
they're kind of dispersed all over the
country
so as that message gets out to the
nation
you know those people that used to live
here during that time might remember
something
and so that's always the value of that
and i think what what chris did with the
podcast was truly put it out nationally
to bring in new information so
we did it did produce some information
that i
i believe was valuable
[Music]
um first to the missteps yes
you know i i i think you know there were
certainly some missteps
were there some things that were done
really really well yes too
you know you can be an investigator and
look at a case that was investigated 10
years ago
look at that case and say well i wish
they would have done this
or i would have done this so you can
always look back and see things that
could have been different but it there
there really is no hiding the fact that
that there were some mistakes made early
on
and and it made it much more difficult
you know that first 48 hours is pretty
critical in a missing person or a
homicide
um and and there was mistakes made that
made
made that that much harder and i think
that's why when i talk about
it's what you can prove it's not what
you believe
i think there's a lot of people that you
know that listen to chris's podcast and
kind of
you know either relive it because they
were around during that time or learned
of the story
and then what they tended to focus on
was
hey why is why aren't we moving forward
and
trying to to to really impress upon
people that you know our duty has to be
to
prove it beyond a reasonable doubt it's
not just we believe this person did it
and we're going to pull them off the
street in the problem of their
their you know their freedom
yes as as denise smart has said
um it's a puzzle and the puzzle
is we're assembling the puzzle and
imagine
if you've ever built a puzzle you found
uh missing pieces
how frustrating that is because you're
looking for the one piece and you find
out there's three pieces
that somebody's taken out of the puzzle
we're not putting it back well this is
what
it has been it's been a puzzle and it's
a
very slow uh process to find
each of those little pieces because at
the end of the day we got to see what
that
puzzle reveals and so that was something
denise said early on to me and i
absolutely agree with it
that's that's the slow process of this
and and finding a little bit
each place so when you ask was there
something of value
my answer would be yes there was
something of value
in various locations that kept coming up
and coming to life i
i really think that's a question that
the da is going to have to answer i mean
once we turn the case over to them
they're the ones that actually file the
charges we know that
the you know 187 of the piano code
murder is is
applicable whether or not something else
will be i think that's
to be determined by the d.a i mean
without finding christian without
religion
how confident are you about evidence
fiscal evidence alone will hold up in
court
well you know what you never know i mean
you can have
you can have you know eyewitnesses and
it doesn't hold up in court
um because of either the admissibility
or believability of the witnesses
so we don't know that until we try it
um i'm confident that we have enough of
a case
to prove beyond a reasonable doubt now
the second part of your question is
without kristen
well there's cases all over the nation
what they call no body homicide
as a matter of fact there's a case in
point that was on 48 hours up in
in placer county where
they prosecuted were successful
it went through appeal they won and
years later they actually recovered
the victim the female victim's body in
that case
so it's done all the time it well i say
it's done
regularly is probably a better answer so
yes i i believe it
it can be done and i think that the
district attorney can be successful
because i think there's enough evidence
to support it my last question is this
is such a high profile case i mean you
can see the
crowd that this is garnered for this
press conference
do you think that this is going to be a
fair trial in san luis obispo county or
will it have to be
so it's a good question and and i i
don't have an answer is there a chance
that it's going to push for a change of
venue yeah
absolutely but that again is going to be
a
a court function to determine that's a
a an item that will be placed in front
of a judge to make that determination
it's a belief that he participated
can't comment on that i i i can't
i can't discuss that other than to say
that every you know every location
i i think i mentioned that we searched
18 locations
um and and most of those involved digs
the most significant one being on
the hillside behind us but but
we're going to continue until we find
her
that's something that is presented in
court i i can't present
a motive or a theory we that's what
court is for
that was answered just a little bit ago
you might have missed it
if not why well i can tell you this
anybody that comes in on a high profile
crime there's probably i'd say a dozen
people right now in custody for murder
um they're all on watch because of the
the level of their charges and it's not
just murder
it could be you know any serious crime
or high-profile crime
that's always an issue and that's always
watched for that particular specific
reason
arresting officers if they um
the the only thing that's been related
to me is that
there there was virtually zero
communication
no response
well as you know i i assume you know
that
a rainy warrant is a warrant that allows
for a law enforcement officer to go into
a home and take somebody
if it was purely a a an arrest that
a peace officer has the authority to
make they could make that in a public
place on the street
but if you're going to into a house you
cannot make that without an arrest
warrant
so in order to to to make sure that he
was
in custody um it was imperative that we
went to
spirit court and a judge signed uh
an arrest warrant in this case a raimi
warrant to allow us if we needed to go
inside a home to take somebody
that we can do that legally
[Music]
sorry let me think
yeah those two uh first two pictures of
paul were taken in san pedro
and the third one was taken to wrong
grounding
uh no
nothing of consequences
then
well at least it was at the end yeah
okay i'm i'm i'm sorry
about their demeanor
oh why not arrest them when he was in
oro grande we we
were well aware he was in a royal grande
we had a warrant to be executed in
san pedro and his residence so yes
it could have happened here and we could
have gone down there but
um you know when you set a timeline when
you talk about an operation of that size
when i'm sending you know 30 people or
20 people
down to southern california and 20
people here
along with forensic people it's it it's
a lot bigger operation than
than meets the eye so
either when you start planning that and
figuring out what personnel you have
once you get to the timeline it's just
better to follow the timeline unless
something really changes and really that
didn't change much
okay um anything further i'm going to
refer you to
um ipo tony coppola and
thank you for coming today
i had a spare one